그냥 막 던져 놓은 거예요. 사실이
중에 팔 만한 거는 몇 개 없습니다.
좀 전체적으로 봤을 때 그렇게 임대
시장이 좋아지진 않았어요. 그래서
실제로 지금 자영업자분들이 폐업
굉장히 많이 하고 있고 지금 공실률이
높아지고 있고 그래서 성수동도 처음에
뭐 2억 찍었다가 다 같이 놀랬다가
어느 순간 3억을 찍고 있고 여기
지금 3억 이상으로도 지금 거래가
되고 있거든요. 지금 실거래가가 안
나와서 그렇지.
어, 우선 기사들 좀 보면은 일단은
대체적으로 거래량이 좀 늘어났다라는
기사들이 좀 많아요. 627 대출
규제 이후에 강남 꼬마빌 거래량이
66%가 껑충 띄었다. 어, 자산가들
머니, 무브가 주목된다라는 기사가
있습니다. 그래서 일단 헤드라인만
보면 어, 정말 작년 대비해서 뭐
진짜 66% 올랐나? 아니면은 언제
기준으로 66%가 오른 거지? 뭐
이런 생각을 할 수 있는데 우선 전
달에가 거래량이 좀 많이 줄었었어요.
그래서 6월 같은 경우에는 거래량이
좀 많이 줄었다가 7월 달에 거래량이
좀 많이 늘었습니다. 그래서 그게
이제 늘어난게 66%인데 그래서
여러분들이 기사를 보실 때 언제
기준으로 늘어나는지 그리고 작년
대비해서는 얼마나 늘어나는지를 한번
체크해 보실 필요가 있는 거
같습니다. 그리고 이제 기사를 좀 더
보면은 빨갛게 보이는 다 상가 매물
강남의 무슨일이라는 기사가 있습니다.
그 실거래가 사이트로 들어가서 이렇게
매물을 표시했어요. 근데 보시면은
굉장히 매물이 많이 나와 있는 것처럼
보입니다. 근데 여기서 좀 허구인게
뭐냐면 21년도 그때 호환기 때도
매물이 이렇게 많았어요. 매물이 어떤
매물인지 보면은 그냥 내놓은 것들이
되게 많아요. 예를 들어서 뭐 내가
10억에 샀는데 부동산에서 계속
전화가 많이 와요. 그래서 아 20억
한 30억쯤면 팔지 이렇게 해서 내놓
매물이 생각보다 많거든요. 그때는
워낙 이제 호환기였기 때문에 그냥 막
던져 놓은 거예요. 사실이 중에 팔
만한 거는 몇 개 없습니다. 그리고
실제로 산다 그러면 안 파는 건물들도
많고 분위기가 안 좋아서 이렇게
매물이 많은게 아니라 그때 이제 완전
피크 때 코로나 이후에 뭐 2020년
2021년도 그때 호환기 때도 이렇게
매물이 많이 나와 있었습니다.
고객분들이 50 때마다 깜짝깜짝
놀랬어요. 빌딩 시장은 되게 좋다
그러는데 매물은 왜 이렇게 많냐?
근데 막상 들어가서 보면은 그냥
내놓은게 많다. 시장이 안 좋아서
이렇게 매물이 많은 건 아니다.
이렇게 보시면 될 거 같고. 그다음에
이제 서울 주요 상권 공실이
내려갔다라는 기사가 있는데 여러분들이
보셔야 될게 서울 전체가 아니에요.
7대 상권입니다. 지금 7대 상권
같은 경우에는 공실률이 조금
줄어들었다. 네. 이런 기사인데
그래서 제가 체감하는 거는 좀
전체적으로 봤을 때 그렇게 임대
시장이 좋아지진 않았어요. 그래서
실제로 지금 자영업자분들이 폐업을
굉장히 많이 하고 있고 지금 공실률이
높아지고 있고 근데 아이러니 한 거는
외국인들이 많이 오는 상권들은 오히려
조금씩 좋아지고 있어요. 그래서 뭐
성수동 연무 장기를 가보더라도 거기서
팝업 스토어도 해 봤지만 국내
사람보다 외국인이 더 많습니다. 그
정도로 외국인이 그 상권을 유지하는데
되게 중요한 부분을 차지하는 거
같아요. 그리고 최근에 어 저도 그
캐대언인가 그거 봤어요. 그게 인기가
많더라고요. 물론 이제 제 취향은
아니어서 이제 끄긴 했지만 잘되는
데는 다 외국인이 받쳐 주는데
같아요. 그리고 앞으로 어 우리나라가
어찌 됐든 생산 가능 인구라든지
이런게 좀 계속 줄어들 거고 소비하는
층이 되게 한정적으로 될 거기 때문에
이런 외국인들이 많이 오는 그런
상권을 좀 주목할 필요가 있는 거
같습니다. 그래서 실제로 기업들도
외국인들이 너무 많이 오다 보니까
비용을 많이 주더라도 인대료를 좀
높게 들어와요. 예. 아니면 직접
매입하기도 하고. 그래서 뭐 성수동
같은 경우에는 팝업 스토어로 진짜
말도 안 되는 금액이 막 들어오기도
하고 그래서 그거와 맞물려서 빌딩
가격도 계속 올라가는 거 같아요.
그래서 성수동도 처음에 뭐 2억
찍었다가 다 같이 놀랬다가 어느 순간
3억을 찍고 있고 그리고 지금 3억
이상으로도 지금 거래가 되고
있거든요. 지금 실거래가가 안 나와서
그렇지. 그래서 그것처럼 양극화가
되게 심해지고 있는데 그 중심에는
외국인이 있고 그리고 기업들이 많이
들어오고 있다. 어 이렇게 보시면 될
거 같습니다. 그리고 공실 늘었는데
빌딩 가격은 그대로 해 가지고 버티는
시장 속 숨겨진 기회 제가 이걸
보면서 느낀 점이 어 원래는 뭐 미국
같은 경우에는 예를 들어서 대출
연장할 때쯤에 만약에 공실이면 대출을
회수합니다. 회수하거나 아니면 빌딩
가치가 막 반토막 반에 반토막 나고
막 그래요. 근데 우리나라는 임대
지금 상황이 안 좋으면 대출 금리가
좀 높아지긴 하지만 상한 요청은 잘
안 하는 거 같더라고요. 실질적으로.
그래서 그러다 보니까 갑자기 막 빌딩
가격이 뭐 반토막이 나거나 반에
반토막이 나거나 뭐 이런 경우는 좀
많이 없는 거 같습니다. 보통 이제
한 2년 3년 정도 적자가 나거나
하면은 부실 직무 기업이 돼서 막
대출을 회수하겠다. 일부를 상하내라
뭐 이런 압박이 들어오긴 하는데 대출
이자를 아예 못 냈을 경우에는 막
이렇게 진짜 경매 들어가고 되게 위기
사항이 있긴 하지만 만약에 대출
이자를 그래도 그동안 꾸준히 냈다라고
하면은 그래도 연장은 되는 거
같습니다. 오히려 건물주 분들이 물론
이제 지금 인대 시장이 안 좋지만 좀
계속 버티고 있는 거 같습니다. 빌딩
가격이 막 폭락하거나 좀 그런 거는
없지 않나? 예. 이렇게 생각을 하고
있습니다. 네. 그래서 시작 뉴스를
가지고 좀 읽어 드리고 지금 현재의
상황에 대해서 제 개인적으로 설명을
드렸는데 앞으로이 지금 코너는 계속할
생각이에요. 그래서 여러분들의 반응이
되게 중요하거든요. 댓글을 남겨
주시면이 코너를 좀 살려보고자
합니다. 느낀 점을 좀 남겨 주시면
감사하겠습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]